المواقع التي يتحدث عنها الجيش قبل قليل
في بيانه الذي
قبل دقائق ويفيد بان هناك اشتباكات انطلاق
منذ صباح اليوم نحن استمعنا الى هذه
الاصوات بوضوح هذه الاصوات كانت الاعنف
والاقوى من حيث
القوه التفجيريه للقذايف التي استخدمت
وانطلقت من الطيران الحربي بكثافه شديده
من
بحر حله حمد حي الاملاك هذه هي المناطق
التي تظهر منها اعمده الدخان
وهي ايضا في منطقه تظهر ايضا ربما مواقع
في محيط القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
الاحياء الغربيه ربما منها هذه الاصوات
تستمعنا لي بقوه شديده قوتها وتاثيرها كان
عاليا جدا الابواب والنوافذ كانت تهتز في
مواقع بعيده عن هذه المنطقه انا شخصيا
احسست بذلك
ايضا ورده تقارير من مواقع مختلفه الاهالي
استمعوا الى هذه الاصوات ومنهم ان استيقظ
يعني في حاله من حالات
الرعب جراء هذه الاصوات القويه لكن هذه
اذا
المواقع التي تم استهدافها وبيان المسلحه
اكد ذلك كانت هناك حصيله من الخسائر
رصدتها القوات المسلحه تمثلت في الاستيلاء
على عدد من العربات الخاصه بقوات الدعم
السريع والعربات مجهزه بالاسلحه والمدافع
الرشاشه ومدافع الكاتيوشا ايضا
بحسب البيان ايضا فان الحصر ما زال جاريا
سعر هذه المعركه هناك معلومات تفيد بان
هناك قاده من قاده الدعم السريع موجودون
في ذلك الموقع
وربما يعني
تم يعني او تمت مهاجمتهم بسلاح الجو في
هذا الصباح
يعني اطلاقا او الطلعات الجويه التي كانت
بالامس كانت قصيره المدى متباعده
التوقيتات ايضا لكن اليوم شاهدنا قصفا
متواصلا لاكثر من تقريبا حوالي ساعتين
متواصلتين قسم مكثف ومركز من هذه المنطقه
شمال
القصر الجمهوري من الناحيه الاخرى وهناك
ايضا اصوات صادره من محيط القصر الجمهوري
ومن محيط القياده العامه كما اسلفت لا
نعرف بعد حجم الحصيله النهائيه لهذه
الجوله من المعركه انجاز وكذلك ولكن
سنتابع بطبيعه الحال عبر مصادرنا في تلك
المنطقه او عبر التواصل مع بعض الزملاء
هناك لمعرفه تفاصيل اوفى
عن المنطقه الاصوات اصوات الاطلاقات
وكذلك اصوات
طيران الاستطلاع نستمع اليه كل تقريبا ربع
ساعه ربما تاكد محمد هذه المعطيات ان
قيادات قياده الصف الاول في دعم ربما ما
زالت فعلا متواجده داخل خرطوم وهناك
ملحقات لها من قوات الجيش وهذا ربما ما
اكده محمد حمدان ايضا قائم في لقاعته
الاعلاميه المختلفه عندما تحدث عن انه
متواجد داخل الخرطوم ويدير المعارك بنفسه
تماما هذه اذا اذا ما جمعنا هذه المعلومات
مع بعضها
وسير هذه
المعاركتها في بعض المواقع هذا كله يؤكد
انا بعض هؤلاء القادم موجودون في هذا او
داخل مدينه الخرطوم غير معلوم على وجه
الدقه اينعم ولكن
يعزز من هذه الفرضيات
وحتى يعني شوهدت لقطات
محمد حمدان قبل وهو في اقرب نقطه ربما من
القصر الجمهوري في احدى اللقطات التي تم
تصويرها عبر الموبايل بطبيعه الحال من
الصعب نؤكد مره اخرى من الصعب الحصول على
المعلومات الدقيقه كل الزملاء الصحفيين
يحاولون ان يوصلوا الاخبار ويتحقق من
الدقه المعلومات عبر مصادر الخاصه على
الارض في بعض المواقع عبر شهود العيان هذه
يعني مهمه شاقه جدا هذه ربما الحرب
الوحيده التي يغطيها الصحفيون من مواقع او
بامكانيات متاحه حسب ما يتيسر لهم لخطوره
الامر تماما ليست هناك من معينات ونحن
يعني في في
بمناسبه اليوم العالمي لحريه الصحه ونتحدث
عن هذا الامر هناك معاناه كبيره جدا
للصحفيين في السودان ليست هناك من معينات
لحمايه الصحفيين الخوذ الدروع المخصصه
لتغطيه هذه النوعيه من
غير متوفره لاي من الصحفيين ولذلك فهم
يقومون بمهمتهم بطريقه يعني
غريبه وايضا شاقه وتصعب من مهمه التاكد
والتحقق من هذه الاخبار وبطبيعه الحال
تحيه لكل الزملاء في هذا البلد الذين
يقومون بهذه المشاقه نعم طيب اسمع الفخذ
بالتذكير الساده المشاهدين بانه نتابع
ايضا هذه الصور الجويه والحصريه لقناه
العربيه والتي تظهر مواقع تمركزات للدعم
السريع في منطقه بحري في حي حله حمد مقابل
القصر الجمهوري وكما ذكرنا مشاهدين يعتقد
ان هذه المنطقه هي تمركزات لقيادات الدعم
السريع لمتابعه
المزيد
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات